[Musica]
ho sempre pensato che il mondo si
dividesse in due grandi squadre il team
sogno nel cassetto fatto da quelle
persone che a quattro anni sanno già
cosa vogliono fare da grandi come la mia
amica maria giovanna che otto anni si
fece lega regalare l'allegro chirurgo
voleva far la dottoressa e poi c'è il
team poche idee molto confuse di cui io
faccio parte
in realtà siamo una squadra che deve di
idee ne ha tante però ha una scarsa
messa a terra pratica è una grande e
unica certezza la confusione
alzi la mano chi di voi fa parte del
team sogno nel cassetto
siete pochini o siete timidi su su su su
su
beh è una minoranza allora alzi la mano
chi fa parte della mia squadra ha poche
idee molto confuse
wow ragazzi siamo davvero un gruppone
potremo fare la réunion annuale prossimo
dicembre 2019 catania a 4 anni ragazzi
volevo fare la danzatrice e per questo
ho studiato per 16 anni danza quale
danza direste voi classica contemporanea
jazz e anche funky per non farmi mancare
niente e dopo 16 anni
pensate a questi poveri genitori che
quasi ogni giorno mi portavano avanti e
indietro al paese a fianco dopo 16 anni
ho deciso di lasciare la danza nell'anno
del mio diploma di insegnamento a 18
anni invece mi sono trasferita a roma
dalla calabria perché volevo fare la
giornalista
indovinate un po dopo tre anni e una
laurea in comunicazione
niente ragazzi ha abbandonato il sogno
di diventare la giornalista da così
riflettendo adesso con il senno di poi
rispetto ai miei sogni nel cassetto mai
realizzati
devo dire che ho trovato due i punti in
comune
voi mi direte cosa hanno in comune il
sogno di fare la danzatrice col sogno di
fare la giornalista
innanzitutto la sindrome dell'impostore
e la stessa sindrome che mi ha detto
fino a un secondo fa martina entrerai
cascando sul tacco 12 sicuro inciampi
sicuro martina ma tu ogni giorno calcoli
la co2 per le aziende parli della parità
di genere ma proprio cavoli tuoi dovevi
raccontare al ted
ebbene l'impostore e quella vocina non
so se ce l'avete anche voi che ogni
volta ci ripete che non ce la possiamo
fare
prima di iniziare prima di fare il primo
passo verso il vostro sogno nel cassetto
l'impostore vi assilla la mente di idee
e vi dice ehi tu non ce la farai
anzi addirittura l'impostore vi mostra
il vostro fallimento e quindi cos'è che
facciamo noi
prima di iniziare prima di fare il primo
passo rinunciamo
e se ci penso d'altronde se penso alla
lancia io non ho mai fatto un provino e
se penso al giornalismo
beh l'impostore ha fatto sì che perché
non mandassi neanche un curriculum
avete mai pensato chi è che ha
l'impostore mamma mia il bavaglio ci
serve per l'impostore il bavaglio
un'altra cosa che ho trovato in comune
tra la danza il giornalismo e relativa
allo stereotipo di perfezione che
qualcosa che non so se riguarda tutti e
due i generi uomo donna
alzi la mano donne alzate la mano se vi
è mai capitato che qualcuno mi dicesse
base ingrassata
senti ma soprattutto per me che per me
che lavora a milano
sei un po pallida non lo so non lo so a
milano vedete il sole donne alzate la
mano se diamo mai fatto dei commenti sul
vostro aspetto fisico uomini parità di
genere
alzate la mano se vi hanno mai fatto
commenti sul nostro aspetto fisico
ragazzi la parità di genere sul tema
stereotipo almeno l'abbiamo vedo delle
mani che restano ancora così immobili
dalla lo so se della disperazione
ebbene si ragazzi siamo cresciuti
giovani ma soprattutto noi donne nella
perenne sensazione di inadeguatezza
ok volenti o nolenti noi siamo
inadeguati e dobbiamo sempre rientrare
in paletti stereotipi esterni ben
definiti fisici o comportamentali
ora vi mostro simona atzori simona
azzurri e una danzatrice italiana di
fama internazionale e anche pittrice non
so se riuscite a vederlo immediatamente
perché non è la prima cosa che vi salta
all'occhio
simona è priva di arti superiori di
braccia se simona atzori avesse pensato
di dover rientrare nei canoni del
balletto classico ragazzi noi non
avremmo mai avuto simona atzori e se vi
capita di vederla mi raccomando
cogliete questa magnifica occasione
perché a questa chioma di capelli ricci
che diventano un tutt'uno con il corpo
si mostri simona atzori avesse creduto
al suo impostore avesse creduto che è
importante seguire degli stereotipi
esterni predefiniti nei quali magari non
tutti rientriamo non avremmo potuto
ammirare e godere delle sue meravigliose
performance nel 2016
io pensavo di sapere qual era il mio
posto nel mondo ragazzi
tutto sommato anche nelle mie poco
poiché idee molto confuse mi sentivo
molto molto a mio agio
avevo trovato un punto di unione
fantastico fra il mio desiderio di
creare
che mi deriva dalla danza e il mio è il
mio la mia passione per il sociale
desiderio di creare impatto lavoravo e
lavoro tuttora come consulente per le
aziende e le accompagnavo e la
accompagno in percorsi di sostenibilità
un po lag retata amberg senza le
treccine con qualche anno in più 20 per
l'esattezza era tutto perfetto ragazzi
nel 2016 avevo appena avuto una
promozione di lavoro
avevo anche una casa una famiglia in
compagno è un progetto di vita ragazzi
era veramente tutto perfetto
indovinate che è successo è arrivato al
mio big bang la mia esplosione in poco
tempo senza preavviso non avevo più una
casa una famiglia un compagno e neanche
un progetto di vita e ovviamente neanche
un lavoro a volte pensiamo di poter
controllare quello che succede che ogni
nostra azione
seguo una contrazione contro azione ma
non è esattamente così arriva
l'imprevisto che scombina le carte della
nostra vita e purtroppo non possiamo
farci niente
queste stato l'anno nel mio big bang
un'esplosione immensa e ragazzi ora lo
dico in maniera molto semplice ci
scherzo su avete presente bridget jones
che quando è stata licenziata e poi
lasciata se chiude inizia a leggere un
sacco di libri motivazionali va in
palestra e in men che non si dica
diventa fighissima ce l'avete presente
guardatela niente io non ho fatto come
bridget jones
l'unico motivo per il quale non mi sono
strappati i capelli per il mio big bang
era perché me li ero tagliati tutti in
un momento di follia non avevo neanche i
capelli quella che è risultata essere un
esplosione per me e sono convinta che
ognuno di voi ha avuto una delusione
personale o professionale il suo
personale big bang è risultata essere
pian piano una espansione che cosa è
successo
improvvisamente le ragazze
che avevo conosciuto anni prima perché
avevo contribuito a fondare
un'organizzazione no profit young women
network rete delle giovani donne avevano
bisogno di me e mi avevano chiesto aiuto
era un momento molto particolare della
mia vita non avevo più lavoro non avevo
più una casa e quindi decido di aiutarle
loro avevano perso il loro leader
la loro presidente aveva deciso di
emigrare in germania per un'opportunità
lavorativa e quindi avevano veramente
bisogno del mio aiuto
decido di io che ero stata per tanti
anni dietro le quinte a testa bassa a
lavorare per l'organizzazione di uscire
fuori allo scoperto di darmi da fare e
con mi aggrego mio grande stupore al s
all'assemblea dell'organizzazione vengo
è lesta presidentessa di young women
network quelle che vorrei condividere
con voi oggi sono le cinque regole d'oro
per sopravvivere al mondo liquido
facciamo che proviamo a sopravvivere al
mondo liquido delle professioni perché
per le relazioni dovremo passare il week
end intero assieme e non basterebbe
regola numero uno per sopravvivere al
mondo liquido bauman perdonami
regola numero uno si tu il tuo punto
fermo non è il nostro status di moglie
fidanzata madre non è il nostro status
lavorativo d'asta ger a dirigente a
definire chi noi siamo è una cosa
completamente diversa
noi siamo il nostro punto fermo noi
siamo e questa è la vera rivoluzione
copernicana
il nostro unico investimento che non ci
deluderà mai e per questo è fondamentale
alimentare il nostro investimento come
si alimenta un investimento così
importante
il nostro punto fermo assecondando le
proprie passioni ma al contempo
alimentando in continuazione le nostre
conoscenze e competenze non solo
competenze che gli psicologi del lavoro
chiamerebbero hard io sono una
consulente sulla sostenibilità devo
sempre aggiornarmi
sul tema ambientale e sociale ma anche
le cose le capacità soft young women at
work mi ha insegnato a investire
continuamente inabilità che non si
apprendono né a scuola e nel mondo del
lavoro sono parlare in pubblico
confidenza di sé capacità di resilienza
che sono delle abilità che ognuno di noi
può acquisire facendo partecipammo
magari a qui a quei training che
associazioni fanno sul territorio e che
ci permettono di essere competitivi
regola numero due per sopravvivere fa il
mondo liquido lasciati contaminare
quando sono entrata young women network
questa rete piena di giovani donne che
fanno cose completamente diverse
ho conosciuto persone ad esempio che si
occupavano di digitale come la mia amica
bis tiana che un vero e proprio guru del
personal branding e del mondo del
digitale grazie a messina sono stata
coinvolta in una serie di conferenze di
formazione di formazioni che non erano
vicini al mio mondo lavorativo della
sostenibilità
ma sapete che c'è alla fine lasciandomi
contaminare da qualcosa completamente
diverso dal mio mondo lavorativo sono
riuscita a trascinare nel mio mondo
lavorativo innovazione e soprattutto ci
avete mai pensato
io sono una libera professionista quanto
debba investire un libero professionista
nel promuoversi tra le organizzazioni e
aziende dai 6 nei servizi grazie a
messina io ho imparato a non contattare
tutte le organizzazioni mandando i miei
servizi ma a lavorare sul mio personal
branding
lasciatemi contaminare regola 3 per
sopravvivere al mondo liquido trova i
tuoi modelli di vita e modelli di vita
non sono soltanto gli eroi dei quali
leggiamo nei libri e che devono
giustamente ispirare nostro cammino ma
son ci sono anche persone vere in carne
ed ossa che possono aiutarci noi e women
at work
organizziamo dei percorsi di mentoring
ogni giovane assegniamo un mentore una
persona di esperienza ma ci sono
tantissime organizzazioni che fanno
che danno queste opportunità e qualora
non dovessero esserci nella vostra città
oppure semplicemente non avete voglia di
far parte di un'associazione ricordatevi
il mondo del web ci permette di mappare
un sacco di professionisti non dico
facciamo stalking però vi assicuro uno
su dieci che voi contattate tra le
persone che ammirate vi risponderà
risponderà il vostro consiglio oppure
dopo una conferenza dopo un title che
non abbiate paura di fermare quella
persona che vi ha ispirato tantissimo e
fategli delle domande credetemi ci sono
molte più persone disposte a condividere
la loro esperienza di quante ne possiamo
immaginare
e ora la mia regola preferita la regola
numero 4 tieni pronta l'opzione b
l'opzione b non è il lavoro che farò se
il primo quello ufficiale va male me la
mia immagine assoluta di benessere di
felicità il mio posto rifugio ora vi
mostro siamo in brasile rio de janeiro
ipanema appena potete andate penso
sempre come consulente che se dovesse
fallire ogni volta che ho paura di fare
qualcosa che penso dio non mi pagherà il
cliente sceglierà un altro dico ragazzi
sapete che c'è
ma io vado a rio a vendere noci di cocco
ma che me ne frega a me della
sostenibilità
regola numero 5 per sopravvivere al
mondo liquido liberati dalle tue paure
sembra banale ma non lo è nessuno di noi
lo fa concretamente ragazzi a
prescindere se facciate parte del team
sogno nel cassetto oppure del team poche
idee molto confuse e ho tanti amici che
fanno switching da un team all altro
mettendo a repentaglio la mia réunion a
prescindere dal vostro obiettivo dal
vostro sogno nel cassetto ricordatevi
una cosa non importa che strada
sceglierete what if
e se non esiste
tante volte dopo il mio big bang mi sono
chiesta e se avessi detto se avessi
fatto non avrei perso il lavoro non
avrei perso il mio compagno non avresti
non aver perso la mia casa e sono
arrivata alla conclusione che sarebbe
stata la stessa identica cosa sarei
sempre finita qui con un alcuna allunga
toia si può dire magari prendendo una
scorciatoia probabilmente una discesa
rotolando facendomi male a prescindere
dalla mia scelta
sarei sempre arrivata qui a parlare oggi
davanti a voi e voi a prescindere dalle
vostre scelte
sareste sempre giunti fin qui ad
ascoltarmi e in fondo non importa dove
vogliamo arrivare
perché la cosa più importante non è
l'obiettivo ma e ogni step che facciamo
per quell'obiettivo è soprattutto la
coerenza che abbiamo nel fare ciascuno
step e il rispetto che abbiamo di noi
stessi
l'amore che abbiamo per noi stessi per
cui ragazzi a prescindere dal vostro
team di appartenenza e dal vostro sogno
vi auguro buon viaggio e vi consiglio di
allacciare le cinture
[Applauso]
[Musica]